oster ruhe teil 2 deutschland soll fünf
tage lang komplett heruntergefahren
werden einzige ausnahme sind supermärkte
am samstag und auch der urlaub fällt für
die meisten aus und genau deshalb ist
die aufregung über mallorca flüge
plötzlich kurs 15 stunden wurde im
kanzleramt verhandelt und am ende stand
ein appell zu mehr vorsicht und weniger
kontakten
der frust ist hoch bei corona mieten
bürgern die auf eine langfristige
strategie von testen und impfen hoffen
es gibt viel kritik an den
unübersichtlichen maßnahmen aber eines
ist klar das virus kennt kein ostern
immer wieder lockdown ist die dritte
welle noch zu brechen unser thema heute
in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
wir haben uns ja im grunde eine neue
pandemie die mutation großbritanniens
hat die mehrheit übernommen unter den
unter den virus das heißt im
wesentlichen haben wir ein neues virus
wir sehen ja auch was es für
auswirkungen hat
wie wir schon wieder die ersten
warnmeldung von der intensiv medizin
bekommen wie jetzt es doch eine sehr
einhellige wissenschaftlicher
einschätzung auch gibt dass die jüngeren
jetzt schwer erkranken lang auch schwer
erkranken und dass es auch bei den
jüngeren natürlich entsprechend
dramatischer verläufe nehmen kann ist
ihm vorsicht hat insgesamt sich
durchgesetzt und zwar bei allen
wir wissen dass corona bleischwer über
dem land liegt und das ist uns alle
gesperrt es ist keine freude der frust
ist groß für jeden von uns selbst auch
die 15 stunden machen nur bedingt spaß
besonders aber im grunde genommen müssen
wir uns immer eines klar machen
dies ist nicht einfach nur die
verlängerung eines luxus wir leben jetzt
in der wahrscheinlich gefährlichsten
phase der pandemie überhaupt söder der
regierende bürgermeister von berlin
müller und die bundeskanzlerin
heute morgen war das schon nach so viel
stunden verhandlung reden wir darüber
was das alles bedeutet und zwar mit
diesen gästen ich begrüße wolfgang
reichert vorsitzender des
hausärzteverbandes berlin-brandenburg er
hat eine hausarztpraxis in
berlin-zehlendorf herzlich willkommen
ich begrüße kerstin münstermann sie
leitet die parlamentsredaktion der
rheinischen post und hatte auch nur
kurze nacht und zugeschaltet ist uns
professor gerd marx er ist präsident der
deutschen interdisziplinären vereinigung
für intensiv und notfallmedizin und
seine intensivstation ist an der
uniklinik in aachen sehr guten tag herr
marx und herzlich willkommen gehören
sell geschäftsführer der ostfriesische
inseln gmbh die touristische vereinigung
aller sieben schönen ostfriesischen
inseln er selbst ist auf borkum hersel
da wären viele von uns jetzt auch gerne
im urlaub
wir haben es ja eben gehört von herrn
söder wir leben jetzt in der
gefährlichsten phase der pandemie
trotzdem fahren viele menschen oder
40.000 sind es ungefähr nach mallorca
dürfen aber nicht
eine zu ihnen nachbau kombi frustriert
sind sie darüber
darüber sind wir sehr frustriert die
entscheidung die dort getroffen wurden
sind einfach in ihrer konsistenz nicht
nachvollziehbar
wir hätten großes verständnis dafür ein
konzept am ende vielleicht auch bewusst
jetzt ganz konsequent der national ist
wenig zu einfach all die welle zu
durchbrechen und anschließend im
tourismus weiter nach ja wieder
hochfahren zu das ist im moment nicht
absehbar eine konzept eine strategie es
wurde uns bei der letzten runde
eigentlich versprochen dass es jetzt mal
auch strategen strategien geben kann für
den tourismus und eigentlich hat ja
wieder nicht
eine große rolle gespielt gestern abend
hätten sie denn der strategie haben die
sich vorbereitet haben sie konzepte wie
sie touristen empfangen können in der
tat haben wir uns mit dem thema
modellregion auch beschäftigt die sieben
ostfriesischen inseln leben ja von dem
positiven umstand dass sie wirklich als
kommunen komplett abgrenzbar sind durch
die zufahrten über die fähre
beziehungsweise über den luftweg
deswegen können wir uns sehr gut
vorstellen nur getestete personen auf
die inseln zu lassen sowie das ja
international auch passiert und dann
weiter mit einem test regime auf den
inseln zu reagieren und somit auch einen
sicheren tourismus auf den inseln
möglich zu machen und wie wenn sie das
jetzt gesehen habe wie gestern abend
darüber gesprochen und verhandelt wurde
und das ist immer noch nicht klar wird
ob zum beispiel reisen der aus mallorca
getestet werden ob die
fluggesellschaften das alles tun ist das
eine diskussion man sagt da ist
hier sollte man eigentlich gar nicht
miteinander vergleichen weil man dann
einfach neidisch ist auch die mallorca
touristen oder wie empfinden sie dass
diese diskussion darüber
ja ich glaube also eine neiddiskussion
muss man an der stelle nicht anfangen
man muss fairerweise sagen dass
natürlich die deutschen reiseziele im
letzten jahr durchaus auch davon
profitiert haben dass international
nicht gereist werden durfte jetzt dreht
würde sich das wenn man es oft die night
ebene hier praktisch umdrehen aber darum
geht es ja an der stelle nicht es geht
einfach darum dass wenn die welle
durchbrochen werden soll gar nicht sich
aufschaukeln soll jetzt über ostern oder
auch sonst konsequent man das
gesellschaftliche leben runtergefahren
werden muss und dazu passt einfach nicht
wenn die reise nach mallorca weiter
möglich sind okay soweit hersel aus
borkum fraumünster man es war eine lange
verhandlungszeit gestern 15 stunden
obwohl sie sich ja schon gut kennen und
das ja nicht das erste mal war dass sie
diese gruppe der so zusammensetzt was
war da so schwierig oder schwieriger als
in den anderen verhandlungsrahmen bei
diesem gipfel hat überrascht dass also
sonntagabend kamen die ersten papiere
die ja immer so gestreut werden im
politischen berlin und in diesen
papieren fiel auf dass tatsächlich
nichts geeilt war und alles in eckigen
klammern stand das heißt ja immer wir
müssen noch mal sprechen und dann
tauchten ausgangssperren auf von
zeitpunkt xx bis morgens um fünf
keiner wusste was man damit eigentlich
genau meint offenbar war es eine
drohkulisse aus dem kanzleramt die
gesagt haben also wenn ihr nicht uns
folgt dann verhandeln wir
ausgangssperren aber es wird doch immer
merkwürdig dass so ein mammut gipfel von
so langer zeit von diesen protagonisten
die sich eigentlich gefühlt ja täglich
sehen und miteinander in kontakt stünden
müssten dann doch kurz vorm scheitern
stand denn das hat der gipfel gestern
also ohne diese einzelgespräche diese
beichtstuhlverfahren gespräche von der
kanzlerin mit dem bundesfinanzminister
spd vizekanzler olaf scholz mit markus
söder mit michael müller der den vorsitz
hat berlins regierender bürgermeister
bei dem ministerpräsidenten gerade wer
das nicht gut gegangen glaube ich und
kann man da sagen gibt es da dann
sozusagen zwei lager also da ist ja auch
immer jemand gewesen der bayerische
ministerpräsident dr
gesagt eher strenger die kanzlerin
wollte immer
das strenger machen kann man ist es nach
parteien aufgeteilt oder nach nord süd
wie muss man sich denn da ist haben wir
gerade gehört hat gesagt team vor sich
das ist also immer er mit der kanzlerin
ich glaube so würde er das persönlich
sehen das interessante war gestern dass
es wirklich quer durch alle parteien
gegen also die nordländer die nord
ministerpräsidenten die eben gern einen
kontakt am urlaub durchgesetzt hätten
die leute nach borkum wir hätten gern
die leute trafen geschickt war der
ministerpräsident günther cdu
manuela schwesig mecklenburg vorpommern
spd also da ging es quer durch die
parteien linien und der
ministerpräsident von sachsen-anhalt
reiner haseloff dem ist ja dann
irgendwann der cdu kanzlerin gegenüber
auch der kragen geplatzt gesagt zu
kommen wir
hast du hier vorschlägt das geht so
nicht und wie gab dann zurück ja aber
dann unterbrechen hier
denn wir so kommen wir gar nicht weiter
also ist natürlich nach außen hin für
die bürger schwer nachzuvollziehen oder
was ist das für eine botschaft aber der
immer gleichen fragen wer ist herr mag
fünf tage kompletter lockdown aber dann
doch der samstag der wird da werden die
supermärkte geöffnet hilft das kann das
im moment helfen diese dritte welle zu
brechen und wo sehen sie diese dritte
welle in ihrer arbeit auf den
intensivstationen schon dass sich der
intensivmedizin ist dass gestern ein
richtiger und wichtiger beschluss
gewesen den wir begrüßen so schwer es
auch fällt
wir wissen dass es geht uns ja auch
persönlich so ein jahr nach pandemie ist
glaube ich sind wir alle wirklich mehr
als angestrengt aber die dritte welle
hat ja schon begonnen
wir sind heute mal 3171
intensivpatienten in deutschland mit 19
die wir betreuen müssen
wir sind bei 2800 patienten ca in diese
dritte welle gestartet das war der
maximalwert der ersten welle im
vergleich dazu bei der zweiten welle
hatten wir weniger als 219 platzieren
auf deutschen intensivstation das heißt
die belastung ist sondern der
ausgangssituation hoch und wir waren
sehr erschrocken über die wirklich
rasant ansteigenden infektionszahlen der
letzten tage
das heißt ja immer dass sie nach zehn
zwölf tagen etwa zwei prozent dieser
patienten dann auch den deutschen
intensivstation behandelt werden müssen
und von der weil es dringend notwendig
aus unserer sicht einen solchen schritt
jetzt zu
ziehen um eben eine chance haben dass
die dritte welle nicht besonders hoch
noch höher als die zweite welle sondern
dass wir da vielleicht tatsächlich
nochmal eine ob essen und brechen nennen
oder abschwächen aber zumindest dass sie
nicht so woraus hält aber wäre es denn
dann nicht sinnvoller gewesen einen viel
härteren lockt auch noch zu machen und
wirklich mal 14 tage alles dicht zu
machen und sollte man nicht diesen
diesen samstag den supermarkt zu öffnen
also jetzt eine einzelne maßnahme aus
zugaben ist glaube ich etwas schwierig
die insgesamt geht es ja darum wie immer
das kennt ja nun mittlerweile auch schon
jeder kontakte zu vermeiden wenn man
sich an die regeln hält wenn man
möglichst im supermarkt fb2 masken trägt
ich glaube dann kann man hier auch die
infektion möglichst vermeiden man muss
ja auch einkaufen können dass das geht
ja nicht anders
insgesamt denke ich dass wir jetzt
einfach schauen müssen was diese
maßnahmen dann nach sich ziehen wir
gehen davon aus dass sie wirksam sein
werden dass sie zu einer reduktion der
neuinfektionen sein führen und damit
auch so eine abschwächung des anstiegs
der intensivpatienten falls dies nicht
der fall sein sollte dann muss man eben
noch einmal neu schauen und
gegebenenfalls eben noch zu anderen
maßnahmen ergreifen so schwer ist auch
uns allen fällt ja man braucht einen
langen atem herr kreischa sie als
hausarzt haben natürlich viel kontakt
mit patient mit menschen die sich sorgen
machen jetzt nach einem jahr mit welchen
sorgen kommen die patienten zu ihnen die
brille viele menschen zünden der
zwischenzeit enttäuscht sie sind
verzweifelt und sie haben tatsächlich
wirtschaftliche probleme und das äußert
sich in der praxis dann mit psychischen
beschwerden also das geht los mit
schlafstörungen unruhezuständen
lustlosigkeit und wir haben im moment
alle hände voll zu tun diese patienten
zu versorgen
weil die alle zeitnah beim psychiater
unterzubringen das unmöglich insofern
haben wir natürlich in den
hausarztpraxen nicht nur die akut
kranken dafür sorgen wer von stopp von
sieben patienten sechs in der praxis nur
einer muss stationär behandelt werden
wir haben jetzt auch die folgen von
kurve zu sehen und zwar nicht in der
erkrankung selbst sondern in den
begleiterkrankungen also depressionen
zum beispiel das hat stark zu
und das sehe ich noch kein licht am ende
des tunnels sie hätten ja sozusagen eine
lichtquelle nämlich im die impfung die
sie anbieten könnten als hausarzt ist es
dabei ihnen sie würden ja auch impfen
aber sie impfen noch nicht wir impfen
noch nicht in der praxis wir haben noch
keinen impfstoff bekommen es gibt praxen
die den impfstoff schon haben wie das
verteilt wurde kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen es überschlagen sich die
ereignisse
es wurden ja auch zeitweise für wenige
tage die impfzentren oder zwei der im
zentrum geschlossen weil ein impfstoffen
wissen in verruf geraten war
wir hatten damals die hoffnung dass
dieser impfstoff stattdessen schnell in
die praxis kommt aber dass er auch
endlich im staff ja das ist auch nicht
geschehen so sind wir im moment auch
wieder auf der dunklen seite und tappt
im dunkeln und warten was kommt aktiv
können wir gar nicht viel machen wirken
nur anbieten dass wir in jeder zeit und
zwar schnell in der fläche das ist jetzt
wichtig dass schnell in der fläche
geimpft wird dass man auch diese
prioritätenliste verlässt weil die
überträger die jungen patienten die sind
eigentlich viel also auch so genau so
wichtig wie die wunderbaren gruppen
sehen weil das ist ja das haben wir
vorher auch linien gehört dass es eben
jetzt auch vermehrt junge leute sind da
würde ich auch ganz gerne meinen mag
noch mal kurz zu fragen also wo sehen
sie eine veränderung
es heißt jetzt durch diese mutation dass
vor allen dingen auch jüngere jetzt
stärker gefährdet sind und die dann auch
wieder jahr länger darunter leiden sehen
sie das schon in indien
das ist richtig die die ersten die
ersten zahlen deuten darauf hin dass
wirklich sehr viele junge menschen sich
infizieren dagegen die über 60 jährigen
deutlich weniger das heißt sie verhalten
sich offensichtlich sehr diszipliniert
und die über 80-jährigen sehen wir auch
sehr selten weil da eben schon sehr
viele geimpft sind
die gefahr ist natürlich dass die
jüngeren menschen das dann wieder in
ihre familien tragen und dort dann
wieder die etwas älteren auch mit
infiziert und die dann letztendlich dann
hospitalisiert werden müssen und einige
von ihnen dann auch leider auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen also schwierig man muss es
wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder etwas
anpassen
sie haben vorhin gesagt sie werden auch
damit einfach
wenn man es jetzt richtig runter fährt
wenn man dann aber auch eine perspektive
hat wer hört ihnen eigentlich zu früh
man hat ja vorhin gesagt die nordländer
haben versucht die nord
ministerpräsidenten ein bisschen was zu
tun für die urlaubsregionen wo haben sie
das gefühl wo werden sie gehört das ist
in der tat schwierig sie müssen sich
einfach vorstellen dass wir als inseln
komplett vom tourismus leben und dem
seit dem ersten november eigentlich mit
unserer wirtschaft runter gefahren sind
wir suchen die ersten gespräche wir
haben erster gesprächsangebote auch
gemacht
das thema wurde jetzt mit der
modellregion ganz zaghaft aufgegriffen
in der letzten woche jetzt vor dem
gipfel aber nichts konkretes ist da
bisher herausgekommen und das ist für
die tourismuswirtschaft in deutschland
insgesamt definitiv nicht genug aber
trotzdem noch mal die frage wenn sie
wenn sie wenden sie sich an die
ministerpräsidenten oder wie machen sie
es wie versuchen sie dass ihre
interessen durchzusetzen da genau also
es gibt ein schreiben der sieben
inselbürgermeister direkt an den
ministerpräsidenten
wir arbeiten auch stark mit den
industrie und handelskammern zusammen
die sich auch an den ministerpräsidenten
an das wirtschaftsministerium wänden
eben auch vorschläge von der basis
machen die braucht es ja für die öffnung
wir erwarten auch gar nicht dass alles
praktisch vor gedacht wird und gleich
funktionieren kann
die notwendigen gespräche kamen bisher
noch nicht zustande
okay das ist auch frustrierend wenn die
gespräche der nicht zustande kommen
fraumünster wenn sie das hören dann das
ist ja schwierig weil es gibt ja in
verschiedenen orten auch in deutschland
derart modellprojekte in rostock kam ihr
das gesehen in tübingen ist das ein
punkt wo die politik mehr drauf eingehen
müsste eigentlich wo man sagen wo man
flexibler in der ganzen corona politik
sein müsste
ich glaube das ist der knackpunkt man
müsste insgesamt flexibler sein nur der
region sind gut und schön aber wenn ich
die berichte aus den praxen höre ich
beobachte schon politik sehr lange und
am ende hatte ich eigentlich immer die
hoffnung dass sich ein kompromiss und
ein stück vernunft durchsetzt
aber wenn ich jetzt auch den gipfel
gestern sehe wo man dann irgendwann auf
die gottesdienste kommen die nur noch
gestreamt werden dürfen keiner hat mit
den kirchen je gesprochen
die haben heute gesagt was wir wissen
gar nichts wir machen das nicht
also es sind so ein kleiner punkt aber
das große die große aufgabe ist doch
jetzt das impfen es gibt nichts was uns
hilft außerdem impfen
und warum es da nicht möglich ist dass
man einen pragmatismus den ja gerade
frau merkel eigentlich auszeichnet
walten lässt und sagt genau es gibt
diese freien impftermine die gibt es
nämlich die gibt es in berlin die gibt
es woanders alle die geimpft werden
wollen sollen kommen und jeder ist ein
gewinn für die gesellschaft ich begreife
das nicht verstehe das schlicht nicht
und dann wenn das läuft dann kann man ja
auch auf natürlich tourismus gastronomie
handel es gibt gute rezepte
es gibt konzepte die wirtschaft hat mehr
gemacht als die länder die die schulen
haben also ich bin selber mutter zweier
söhne die schulen besuchen wenn es den
guten schulleiter nicht gibt dann gibt
es überhaupt keine idee für diese
schulen also warum nicht auf die
wirtschaft hören einbinden auf die
wirtschaft vielleicht auch setzen wenn
es darum geht den impfstoff irgendwie in
arztpraxen zu bringen aber dass das
nicht geregelt ist
er ist gestoppt eine menge leute die
euch darüber frustriert sind herr kreis
ist es wo werden sie denn gehört weil
sie sagen sie sind eigentlich bereit wir
könnten doch jetzt und warum
funktioniert das nicht was es in ihrer
erklärung
ich meine wir sagen schon unsere
meinungen ich habe zum beispiel vor
einem jahr schon mal gesagt an
entscheidender stelle vor einem jahr
dann bist du berlin dicht machen so mehr
oder weniger zum spaß und es war bei der
ersten welle
da hieß es das geht ja gar nicht wir
haben die freizügigkeit ist viel
wichtiger
naja hab ich gesagt dann warten wir doch
erst mal ab was passiert
jetzt ist die freiheit massiv
eingeschränkt es geht gar nicht anders
und das problem was ich sehe ist das so
langfristig das vertrauen von großen
schichten der bevölkerung in die politik
verloren geht
also ich möchte nicht von corona leugnet
oder sonstwas reden die haben eh kein
vertrauen aber ich sehe es bei dem
durchschnitts patienten dass der im
moment gar nicht mehr darauf achtet was
die politik sagt er lässt sich treiben
hat keine großen erwartungen die fragen
mich was sie tun sollen und ich sag
tragen sie die maske halten sie hygiene
vorschriften einhalten sie abstände ein
und so weiter und so fort
da geht im moment sehr viel den bach
runter und das finde ich sehr schade in
diesem land die politik hat sicherlich
vieles richtig gemacht aber zu spät und
sie hat vieles falsch gemacht und das zu
früh insofern sind da viele baustellen
und man kann das nicht an einem punkt
jetzt klären
es gibt viele punkt das ist ein ganzes
mosaikbild und dann ein gesamtkunstwerk
aber dann geht man letztendlich sowie
professor mark seien in der klinik und
dann hat man all das ergebnis nämlich
dass immer mehr menschen krank werden
und das ist schwieriger wird auf den
intensivstationen wo würden welche
botschaft würden sie sich dann mehr
wünschen von der politik also ich glaube
das ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass wir
diese zeit auch die zeit der des
erneuten doktor uns satt maßnahmen dazu
nutzt wenn man sich die lage betrachtet
und die informationen bezüglich der
verfügbaren impfstoff dosen gehen wir im
moment davon aus dass ihr so wie es in
q3 also ende september dann doch viele
vielen bürgern oder sogar ein
bürgerinnen und bürger also ein
impfstoff angebot machen können und ich
glaube ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt ein
konzept entwickeln dass wir transparent
machen welche monats und wie viele
impfdosen zu erwarten wie kommen wir da
voran wie verhalten wir uns dann mit den
regeln mit den geimpften mit den noch
nicht geimpften ich glaube und hier in
eben vielleicht dann flexibel test
strategien glaube wenn man hier einen
konzept macht bis eben über den sommer
hinaus dass er glaube ich sehr wichtig
um das vertrauen was er eben angedeutet
worden ist was bei einigen jetzt nicht
mehr so hoch ist wieder gewinnt und dass
wir da wirklich gemeinsam diese pandemie
bewältigen können aber das ist das doch
ein bisschen spät und jetzt ein konzept
zu machen
ich bewundere da gerade ihre geduld herr
marx ja was heißt geduld also ich offen
gestanden
es nutzt ja immer nichts wenn wir nach
hinten guckt außer dass man vielleicht
analysiert und deswegen besser nach
vorne kommt es geht ja jetzt schon heute
an nach vorne zu schauen und pragmatisch
das beste aus der situation zu machen
frau münstermann warum war da nicht
früher schon ein konzept so viele sagen
ja wir brauchen diese langfriststrategie
aber irgendwie haut das ja nicht hin
naja langfriststrategie also eine
evaluation der maßnahmen hat es nicht
gegeben also was was ist denn mit den
verschiedenen locker uns passiert da
sind wir immer irgendwie durch und dann
war um alle waren froh haben gesagt wir
öffnen
aber die idee dass man schließt du womit
man infektionen vermeidet das kommt
jetzt so allmählich nach und nach mal
hoch aber die langfriststrategie die zu
recht angemahnt wird die gibt es nicht
und das finde ich ist wahrscheinlich der
größte fehler gewesen auch über den
winter hinweg nur auf zahlen starren
aber nichts zu überlegen wie gehen wir
damit um und wir haben vor ein paar
wochen noch über eine instanz von 35
gesprochen
heute sind wir froh wenn es um die 100
ist das zeigt ja auch dass das verfolgen
der ziele immer wechselt und dass da der
durchblick fehlt ist schon kann man
schon verstehen also nicht nur bei den
leuten sondern auch bei denen die das
beobachten ja das führt dann dazu was
sie gesagt hat wir greifen dass die
leute es nicht mehr ernst nehmen und
dann die maßnahmen nicht mehr einfach
nicht mehr dran halten also das stimmt
zum teil pauschal kann man das wirklich
nicht sagen also gerade die älteren
patienten halten sich drängen an die
regeln wo ich so ein bisschen vermisse
das ist bei den jugendlichen das sehe
ich ja abends wenn ich aus der praxis
raus geht dann sind die zusammengerottet
ist so wie wir es früher auch getan
haben da gibt es keine masken ja das ist
das problem also ich will das noch mal
aufgreifen weil sie gesagt haben man
hätte aus dem lockt das lernen müssen
man hätte aufklären müssen
und man hätte ganz viel impfstoff
bestellen müssen damit der ganz schnell
an die menschen kommt das sind sachen
das hat mir einfach nicht gelernt jetzt
hat man das will dann muss man es eben
jetzt machen
ja natürlich lernt man wenn man
rückwärts guckt aber man ist ja nach
vorne gerichtet der impfstoff muss
schnell in die praxen der impfstoff muss
verimpft werden an die
bevölkerungsgruppen gar nicht mehr so
nach der priorität sondern nach der
kontakt zahl ich glaube dabei als
reinigungsfrau im krankenhaus
viel größeres bretter sein kann als eine
80-jährige die vielleicht allein im heim
lebt
insofern muss die putzfrauen genauso
schnell geimpft werden wie der polizist
oder der feuerwehrmann oder der post
wurde um die mfa welche strategie wäre
denn für sie wichtig oder jetzt wenn der
osterurlaub so nicht stattfinden kann
wie sie gehofft haben also denken sie
jetzt an pfingsten denken sie an den
sommerurlaub was was planen sie denn
jetzt
wenn die politik nicht wie lang für alle
ge hat da möchte ich kann schon ein
fraumünster man anknüpfen
dass das ist ja genau das thema das die
nächsten tage und wochen einfach nicht
ungenutzt bleiben dürfen nur weil wir
jetzt in die dritte welle rhein fahren
sondern eins ist und touristikern ja
definitiv klar wenn reisen wieder
möglich sein soll dann ja nicht sofort
so wie wir es früher erkennen sondern
wir werden mit einschränkungen
das reisen ermöglichen tests wären rolle
spielen impfungen wäre eine rolle
spielen digitale kontakt verfolgungs
methoden wie eine rolle spielen
und diese konzepte die müssen doch jetzt
gebaut werden damit dann wenn wieder ein
sich die tür öffnet diese auch greifen
können und nicht dass wir dann erst
anfangen weil dann sind wir tatsächlich
an einer stelle wo es vielleicht dann zu
pfingsten immer noch nicht geht oder im
sommer immer noch nicht geht und das
wäre wirklich fatal
gucken sie jetzt auf den sommer also wir
hoffen natürlich dass der sommer
zumindest ähnlich funktioniert wie der
letzte sommer der war natürlich auch mit
einschränkungen versehen aber doch hat
der auf den inseln den gästen wirklich
ein gutes urlaubsgefühl gebracht und das
sollte bitteschön auch in diesem jahr
wieder möglich sein und davon bin ich
auch überzeugt dass das geht wenn sowie
die runde jetzt auch gesagt hat wir
wirklich an konzepten und strategien
arbeiten aber das ist schwierig herr
marx wenn man jetzt man schaut auf diese
dritte welle man schaut auf diese
mutation dann gibt es jetzt diese
diskussion über die über lieben menschen
die nach mallorca fliegen weil dann auch
weil es da heißt da gibt es die die
separaten brasilianische mutation und
das könnte ein großes
nehmen werden wie problematisch ist es
das 40.000 menschen nach mallorca
fliegen
wenn die wieder zurückkommen bibel sagt
welche folgen könnte das haben für uns
hier ja also die brasilianischen mutter
ist tatsächlich ein szenario was wir uns
gar nicht so gerne klar machen wollen
weil diese diese mutation gegen einige
impfstoffe resistent ist
es gilt jetzt tatsächlich die
verbreitung zu vermeiden das heißt
letztendlich für die urlauber meines
erachtens dass sie auf jeden fall bei
ihrer rückkehr getestet werden sollten
um entsprechende verbreitung hier in
deutschland und auch woanders zu
vermeiden
man muss allerdings auch sagen
letztendlich das hat man ja auch bei der
britischen mutante gesehen da gab es ja
auch versuche die ausweitung zu
verhindern dass vor allen dingen wochen
oder monaten das hat ja auch nicht
funktioniert von daher ist es auch
wichtig auch die brasilianische mutter
hatte letztendlich inso strategie
überlegungen einzubeziehen ich meine
ohne die britische mutante werden wir
jetzt ja auch in einem ganz in einer
ganz anderen situation das ist schon
richtig was die kanzlerin gesagt hat
dass das eine neue pandemie ist und wir
müssen eben jetzt die möglichen
szenarien wirklich alle durch planen und
dafür jeweils auch eine antwort haben
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig damit
wir dann eben dieses auch transparent
machen können und gemeinsam da ja die
besten entscheidungen treffen können und
was wären denn die besten entscheidungen
ja also wie gesagt im moment versuchen
möglichst die ausweitung der
brasilianische mutante zu vermeiden
haben ergeben dass je mehr wir impfen
desto weniger herr möglichkeit gibt es
ja dass ich neue mutationen entwickeln
das ist das ist das entscheidende und
bis dahin müssen wir einfach gucken dass
wir die kontakte vermeiden so schwer es
auch verhält so es ist ja immer sind ja
immer dieselben aussagen die wir seit
monaten treffen hygieneregeln kontakt
vermeiden abstand halten aber das ist im
moment so lange wir eben nur so wenige
menschen geimpft haben ist dass das was
wirklich hilft um eben neu infektionen
zu vermeiden und auch die entstehung von
neuen mutationen das ist das ist das
mittel was in diesem moment zur
verfügung haben wenn das so gefährlich
ist und die kanzlerin sagt wir haben
eine neue eine neue pandemie frau
münsterland als botschaft die angekommen
ist jetzt heute in der nacht ist doch
eigentlich ja ostern dürft ihr das nicht
so machen wie ihr wolltet ihr dürft zwar
samstags einkaufen gehen aber die
familie muss zu hause bleiben in den
urlaub fahren dürfte ja auch nicht es
ist ja nicht die botschaft wir impfen
jetzt so schnell wie möglich das ist
leider nicht die botschaft die botschaft
ist wir haben wie auch immer geartete
ruhetage interessant war heute dass man
bei gesprächen mit mitgliedern der
bundesregierung die gar nicht so genau
wussten was wurde da eigentlich
beschlossen es gebe heute erst eine
runde der chefs der staatskanzleien die
sich überhaupt abgesprochen haben
was sind denn ruhetage haben arztpraxen
fünf tage geschlossen haben die
apotheken fünf tage geschlossen wird
denn weiter getestet das war unklar das
hat man dann aber es steht drin ja die
impfzentren sind weiter offen immerhin
die testzentren auch mit dem geimpft
werden sollen leiter aber am ende heißt
ist die klare botschaft das ist ja auch
richtig dass die politik das sagt also
bleibt zuhause haltet abstand wir haben
diese corona rotation da können wir
jetzt alle kommen wir nicht raus aber
die überlegung was man dass man
eigentlich sagen wo es fliegt auf keinen
fall bleibt hier und vielleicht also gut
man hat seitens des auswärtigen amts
argumentiert dass man das hat aufheben
müssen diese reisewarnung weil man da
auch in juristische komplexe hinein
kommt vielleicht hätte man es ein
bisschen versteckt und mal unter den
tisch fallen lassen und das nicht der
run auf mallorca wo man jetzt ja auch
nichts mehr machen kann auch dort
herrscht noch dauern in einer gewissen
weise gar nicht erst aufgetreten wäre
den leuten jetzt zu sagen möglicherweise
kommt ihr nicht mehr in unser land rein
weil ihr dann infiziert seit und werde
dort getestet was passiert denn mit
einer familie die mit zwei kindern in
palma steht und jetzt corona positiv ist
was geht die dann in den hotels auf
mallorca und wird dort wie auch immer
behandelt besitzt die in einem anderen
flieger also die konsequenz eben gar
nicht bedacht dabei eigentlich ja etwas
was ist für sie ist nach diesem nach
dieser neuen bund länder nach diesen
neuen bundesländer treffen gibt es auch
wo sie sagen ja da das ist auch was
positives weil es ist auch endlich mal
dass gesagt wird ja wir haben
wahrscheinlich eine neue pandemie also
schon allein die erkenntnis dass es neue
pandemie ist oder eine dritte welle dass
das jetzt eigentlich egal
das ist schon wichtig das ist überall
ankommt und aus dem grund ist es eben
wichtig es ist auch schon gesagt worden
dass ganz schnell flächendeckend geimpft
wird damit es gar nicht zu neuen
mutationen kommen kann und dass damit
das virus auch kein wird findet weil
wenn jemand geimpft ist ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er sich noch mal
steckt minimal
insofern ist das schnelle impfen ist das
wichtigste was wir im moment vor haben
sie große rückhalt zurückhaltung von
patienten dass sie sagen also astra
weniger würde ich aber nicht nehmen ist
das immer noch so viel oder sagen
hauptsache gehen also jeder impfstoff
ist besser als keiner
ja und ich finde den impfstoff von
astrazeneca nicht schlecht man hat ihn
für einige tage gestoppt das war meines
erachtens übertrieben wenn man ihnen
gestoppt hat hätte man zumindest den
nicht für männer stoppen dürfen weil von
diesen 14 komplikationen hat es nur eine
bei einem angegeben die anderen 13 bei
frauen ein herz für männer nicht stoppen
dürfen und man hätte ihnen aber
ansonsten freigeben können für alle die
den impfstoff wollen
insofern hat man viele wertvolle zeit
verloren und das ist genau
kontraproduktiv weil es geht darum
schnell flächendeckend zu impfen und
nicht durch verzögerungen
das zu verlangsamen wie läuft das impfen
auf den inseln hersel das würde ich auch
gerne wissen wie funktioniert das bei
ihnen und ist das ein punkt wo sie sagen
ja wenn wir bald alle geimpft sind dann
können wir auch wieder wunderbar unsere
hotels aufmachen wir haben ja zwei
themen das eine thema ist inwieweit sind
die einheimischen gehüpft und das zweite
tier man wie weit sind die gäste
gekämpft
wir hatten in der letzten woche die
erste impfkampagne auf der insel
im vorfeld wurde immer diskutiert ob die
insulaner aufs festland dazu müssen oder
nicht
und das lief recht reibungsfrei und war
auch sehr erfolgreich und inwieweit wie
finden sie es richtig wenn zum beispiel
geimpfte eine art pass bekommen und dann
urlaub machen zu dürfen
also wir haben ja zwei themen die wir
besprechen wenn die touristische öffnung
wieder erfolgen soll dass es entweder
der nachweise über die impfung oder die
nachfolge der nachweis über ein test
beides zusammen würde im moment aus
unserer sicht eine öffnung szenario
ermöglichen
je mehr menschen geimpft sind desto
weniger muss getestet werden
vorausgesetzt es gelingt jetzt auch dem
acker jeder nachweis dass die getestete
die geimpften personen auch nicht mehr
ansteckend sind okay frau minister man
was erwarten sie jetzt nach diesen
beschlüssen die ja so kritisiert sind
kritisiert werden auch in der zustimmung
zur politik
ich glaube das hängt im wahljahr der von
dem sommer ab der kommen wird werden wir
da im biergarten sitzen einigermaßen
durchgeimpft in der bevölkerung
möglicherweise nicht nach thailand aber
in deutsche gebiete verreisen können
dann glaube ich so ist der mensch nun
mal gibt es schon ein großes verzeihen
auch und man wird auf diese monate
zurückblicken
geht das jetzt aber so weiter angenommen
wir kommen eine dritte welle die
intensivstationen laufen voll sind
schreckliches wort aber werden immer
voller
der lock down bringt nichts diese fünf
tage lockdown dann glaube ich kommt die
politik allmählich wirklich in ein unter
einen rechtfertigungsdruck der dann in
einen vertrauensverlust führt und vor
einem jahr gab es eine fernsehansprache
der bundeskanzlerin
ich glaube ich vieles rausgerissen hat
also die hat sie hat ja vermittelt
vertraut mir folgt mir ich werde euch da
irgendwie durch bugsieren und das fehlt
mir gerade komplett erwischt wie schnell
würde wird man merken ob dieser lockdown
über ostern funktioniert sie laufen
immer so ein bisschen dahinter so zu
sagen wann wann weiß man dass es
sinnvoll ist sinnvoll gewesen ist ja das
ist ja niemand schuldig habe gesagt
entschuldigung ich habe meine ich habe
einen marx angeschaut und ihnen auch
gemeint als mediziner entschuldigung ich
habe er sich gesagt also wann weiß man
dass das funktioniert hat entschuldigung
ja gut auch bei die intensiv zahlen
laufen jetzt tatsächlich mal etwas
hinterher aber wir werden das ja relativ
schnell auch bei den insolvenzzahlen
sehen und ich muss gestehen ich gehe
davon aus dass wir einen effekt durch
diesen durch diese maßnahmen sehen ja
nicht nur über ostern sondern ja jetzt
bis mitte april
wir gehen davon aus dass das wir einen
effekt sehen insgesamt und auch bei den
intensivstationen und dass deswegen sind
es ja auch die richtige entscheidung
gewesen so schwer sie fallen und wenn
ich das noch mal sagen darf was dieses
thema mit astrazeneca ich glaube das
kann man gar nicht überbetonen das würde
ich gern noch einmal aufgreifen
also man muss hier wirklich risiko
nutzen abwägung und ja es gibt diese
nebenwirkungen bei den bei einigen über
das internationale praxis sich noch
etwas mehr als die 13 14
aber jeder geimpfte jede geimpfte hat ja
dann nach der ersten info bereits quasi
keine schweren verläufen er zwar zeigen
das zeigen die daten aus schottland und
von daher ist das wirklich wichtig dass
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger auch
diesen impfstoff nutzen also impfen
impfen das ist das auch was sie sagen er
greift werden sie denn aufmachen am
gründonnerstag dann oder wissen sie das
nicht wir werden auf machen wir haben
auch patienten die betreut werden müssen
bis jetzt nicht näher darauf eingehen da
ist es einfach erforderlich dass wir
aufmachen
wir können höchstens mal zwei tage
hintereinander zu machen aber kann
niemals drei tage
insofern werden wir aufmachen müssen und
ich bin noch was zu den supermärkten
sagen das müsste man wirklich mal
überlegen ob es sinnvoll ist dass in
einem samstag auf zu machen oder ob man
nicht an allen tagen ein bisschen
aufmachen sollte dann ist ja die
konzentration der patienten der menschen
in diesem supermarkt geringer
andere länder haben es anders gemacht
natürlich wird man es hinterher erst
wissen aber prospektiv hätte ich schon
gedacht dass man lieber die zeiten
streckt und das einkaufen erlaubt
vielleicht sogar in den abendstunden und
in vielen ländern hat man auch nach
altersgruppen die leute einkaufen lassen
damit sie sich nicht vermischen
das sind alles dinge das hat man ihr gar
nicht an diskutiert oder zumindest ist
es sich nach draußen gedrungen
hätte man tun können so flexibler sein
können und wie viel eigenverantwortung
trauen sie den bürgern zu nach einem
jahr pandemie wo man sagt man weiß doch
eigentlich wie man sich jetzt zu
verhalten hat wäre das nicht möglich
dass man sagt mit mehr
eigenverantwortung könnten wir uns auch
mehr lockerungen leisten ich denke dass
die einzig jetzt größer ist als vor
einem jahr
oder von einem dreivierteljahr nur dazu
kommen jetzt ermüdungserscheinungen das
hebt das wieder auf ja und dann haben
wir es eine sonder diskrepanz eben
manche halten es einfach nicht mehr aus
die müssen auch mal raus und die können
nicht in wänden zu vier wänden sitzen
das ist auf die dauer das macht auch
krank abid eingangs ja auch geschafft
die krankheiten haben mit
eigenverantwortung oder wie es ihrer
ihre gedanken dazu wenn die bürger mehr
eigenverantwortlich sein könnten und
touristische angebote die halt eben
konzepte haben restaurants die hygiene
konzept der hotels die hygiene konzepte
haben würden sie sagen das kriegen wir
auch so hin
die leute halten sich schon daran also
eigenverantwortung spielt glaube ich in
der gesamten pandemie bewältigung eine
große rolle
ich glaube dass der staat am ende auch
überfordert wäre die komplette
verantwortung für die bewältigung zu
übernehmen
insofern geht es tatsächlich darum in
die verantwortung zu nehmen einmal die
leistungsträger und ich glaube die
werden ihrer verantwortung auch sehr
sehr gut gerecht indem sie in der
vergangenheit also vor allem im letzten
jahr bereits schon sehr sehr gute
hygiene konzepte erarbeitet haben und
auch umgesetzt haben und man kann so
habe ich es auch erlebt gut an die gäste
appellieren und sie halten sich dann
auch an die vorgaben aber dann ist es
doch umso frustrierender dass sie dann
trotzdem alle schließen müssen dass das
ist in der tat so also sie müssen sich
einfach vorstellen dass von den sieben
ostfriesischen inseln im moment wenn ich
es richtig im kopf habe vier inseln gar
keinen corona infizierten haben zwei
haben jeweils ein
und dann die siebte insel hat drei
infizierte
die sind alle seit seit tagen
beziehungsweise mehreren wochen schon
isoliert und wir fragen wir uns warum
das nicht funktionieren kann und wenn
man dann den tourismus nur als einzige
wirtschaftszweig hat dann ist das ja
frustrierend
ja und wie viel menschen sind da hat man
ihre existenz bedroht in ihrer existenz
bedroht das ist natürlich schwierig zu
sagen
der tourismus ist sehr kleinteilig
organisiert das sind ja ganz ganz viele
kleinere betriebe
aber man muss ist einfach hier nehmen
dass seit dem ersten november verdienen
die touristischen betriebe schon wieder
kein geld kommen sollen wenn sie das
hören so wenig corona infizierte und wir
haben ja sonst auch mal geschaut welche
landkreise welche incidents haben
warum kann man das nicht erlauben ihrer
meinung nach zur wahrheit gehört ja dass
die menschen irgendwie auf die inseln
kommen müssen also was man von der
politik ja vermeiden will es nicht durch
den einzelnen menschen nicht an diese
auf diese insel zu lassen sondern die
mobilität auf dem weg dahin
die zugfahrt und die autobahnraststätte
wie auch immer also man will eigentlich
unterbinden dass die menschen sich
bewegen und das ja auch wenn man die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems als
maßstab nimmt zurecht aber dieses wissen
haben wir jetzt genau ein jahr und
vielleicht wäre es in diesem jahr
möglich gewesen sich dinge zu überlegen
wie es trotzdem möglich ist dass
menschen vielleicht auch zur erholung
doch so reisen oder sich unterhalten
können es gab ja den vorschlag dass
zumindest im eigenen bundesland das
möglich jetzt damit sind die nordländer
ja gestern an den start gegangen
und vielleicht hätte es dann gutes
konzept gegeben aber die sorge der
bundeskanzlerin war sollte sich das
gestern formuliert dass da ein damm
bricht also wenn wir das hier erlauben
wenn wir das in dem bundesland erlauben
aber in bayern zum beispiel nicht weil
da die instanzen zu hoch sind dann gibt
es klagen dann gibt es noch ein größeres
gefühl der ungerechtigkeit und das
steckt dahinter dass die insel der
sichere ort ist als berlin-mitte da bin
ich glaube ich jeder überzeugt wie
wichtig wäre das für die gesundung herr
greiser dass man sagt okay man darf dann
auch mal urlaub machen oder das eben
dann doch ein zu hohes risiko also ich
sag mal so wenn wenn die menschen
diszipliniert sind und in disziplin hat
in der tat zugenommen das beobachte ich
wie so oft ein paar randgruppen dann
spricht nichts gegen einen spaziergang
um den grunewaldsee oder abends mit dem
hund gassi gehen das muss möglich sein
und es muss auch möglich seien zu
verwandten zu fahren es muss auch
möglich sein auf eine insel zu fahren
wenn dort getestet wird und wenn man
vorher sich test lässt bzw werden
geimpft ist das muss möglich sein also
die grundrechte sollte man schon so
langsam wieder zurückbekommen wenn die
voraussetzungen stimmen aber das ist ja
genau das problem ist ja eigentlich
funktioniert der markt wo wo ist für sie
der der indikator was ist für sie das
wichtigste um zu messen welche maßnahmen
ergreifen muss dann doch die zahl der
intensivpatienten ist es dieser wert ist
also woran muss man sich denn da
wirklich muss man das messen
ich glaube der unterschied jetzt in
dieser dritten welle oder der neuen
pandemie im vergleich zu den bisherigen
jahr ist ja dass die britische mutation
so viel ansteckender wie wir haben
kontakt leser ist das darf man nicht
unterschätzen das heißt also wenn immer
menschen in bewegung sind irgendwo
hinfahren ist die gefahr der ansteckung
nochmal deutlich höher als sie in der
vergangenheit war und ich glaube das ist
eben auch der grund warum diese maßnahme
ist dann doch notwendig sind
der wert ist mehr eine ganz kurze
nachfrage noch mal zu der ansteckung
damit man es auch wirklich versteht ist
es dann sind es mehr
rose die gefährlich sind oder ist gehen
die tragen die weiter wodurch also ist
es ansteckender macht es sinn oder bin
ich dann trotzdem mit meiner fb2 maske
gegen diese dagegen ansteckung geschützt
ja es ist mir zwei masten sind sehr
wirkungsvoll sie sehen es zum beispiel
in kitas
wir hatten eigentlich bisher in den
kitas sehr selten aus wo ich jetzt mit
der britische mutation wird das immer
häufiger berichtet also der der effekt
wenn wenn ein mensch infiziert ist dann
in einem innenraum zb andere anzustecken
ist offensichtlich sehr sehr hoch okay
aber sie wollten noch was weiter
ausführen
zudem wir hatten ja nach dem wert nur
alles gut genau
also der wert ist sicherlich sehr
wichtig um zu sehen sind wir im
exponentiellen wachstum oder nicht aber
es ist eigentlich wiener klinik welche
ein patient behandelt sagt ja auch nicht
das ist der eine wert sondern ich habe
dieses potpourri dieses puzzle von
verschiedenen informationen und so ist
es hier eben auch er wert incidence wert
verfügbare intensiv kapazitäten oder
auch überhaupt krankenhausbetten das
sind alles verschiedene informationen
die man zusammen tragen muss und auf der
grundlage letztendlich die entscheidung
treffen
ok fraumünster man was er am 12
april kommt diese runde wieder zusammen
dann wird wieder geschaut wie das
funktioniert bis dahin haben leute
vielleicht ein bisschen über ostern
entspannen können was erwarten sie von
der nächsten diskussion
das ist ja mittlerweile wirklich wie und
täglich grüßt das murmeltier diese runde
ich wage da auch keine prognose und ich
glaube es hängt wirklich an den zahlen
und an der entwicklung aber was sicher
nötig ist die menschen werden bis dahin
noch pandemie müder seien noch genervt
das geht ja auch an den politiker nicht
vorbei die merken dass ja die sind auch
deshalb so unter anspannung weil das ja
an sie herangetragen wird und ich glaube
jeder politiker ist ganz wichtig der der
kann locker hat oder was es lockert
lässt einfach ein leben wieder zu und
die hoffnung glaube ich aller gestern
beteiligten einschließlich der
beobachter und alle die das verfolgen
ist dass wir in
vier wochen nicht ganz drei wochen zu
einem anderen schluss kommen können und
vielleicht im mai zumindest mal wieder
draußen einen kaffee trinken können und
haben sie den das gefühl dass die dass
die bundeskanzler darin immer noch
diejenige ist die ist wirklich leitet
oder ist es der chor der
ministerpräsident ministerpräsidenten
der es eben wirklich da so schwierig
macht
das wechselt eine zeit lang hat sie es
nicht leiden können da waren dann
öffnungs schritte ziemlich deutlich und
ehrlicherweise hatte sie mit ihren
negativprognosen ja immer recht
aber das ist politisch natürlich nicht
besonders schön und auch nicht besonders
opfer tun aber wenn man ihr gefolgt wäre
in ihren wissenschaftlichen nüchternen
analysen see ist vielleicht heute anders
aus ich glaube gestern abend hat sie
noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht
vielleicht das letzte mal aber sie hat
die verantwortung übernommen und
durchgesetzt denn eigentlich ist man ja
ins bett gegangen mit der idee auch
vielleicht ostern doch oma opa
aufgewacht ist man mit einem mit einem
block dauer verlängert wurde
wir bleiben zu hause ist das motto auch
für dieses ostern nicht nur für das
letzte ganz herzlichen dank herr marx l
und frau münstermann und morgen schauen
wir noch mal auf die zukunft der union
laschet oder so da fragen wir dann wäre
für die union aus der krise ich hoffe
sie sind dabei bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]